good morning Hank it's Tuesday thanks
for giving me your cold while we were
together in Florida I'm just kidding no
thanks what is the opposite of thanks
shanks shanks for the cold Hank anyway
it's question Tuesday the day that
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters let's get right to it would
you rather be a world-famous banjo or
accordion player I'm gonna go with
world-famous banjo I mean being an
accordion player it would be fun and
everything but I have to be human and
all things being equal I think I'd
rather be a banjo hey how do you feel
about the trailer for the tiffy ohs
movie leaking kind of upset mostly
because the trailer is not like an
iPhone video of a low-res screener it's
in high-definition and it's beautiful
also it is debuting tomorrow
so you can see it then you only have to
wait like 24 hours to hold you over here
is the world premiere of a 10 second
teaser I can't tell you how thankful I
am for our little infinity
that is what it really looks like French
the llama
I am excited I'm still trying to make
that into a thing hey speaking of movies
if a movie were to be made about Dave
Greene who do you think would play him
Benedict Cumberbatch Sean do you like
Dave Greene more than you like Hank I'll
tell you one thing Dave never gave me a
horrible cold my daughter doesn't like
pizza is she a monster doesn't give me
any pleasure to tell you this but yeah I
think she might be a monster I mean it
could be lactose intolerance or a gluten
thing but it's most likely monster Ness
how excited are you about Esther's book
coming out today
so flippin excited this book is
wonderful please run don't walk to your
nearest bookstore to get a copy there's
also a link in the doobly-doo where you
can buy one on the Internet if I'm gonna
do a live show tomorrow read from the
book and talk more about it so I'll see
you then have you ever thought about the
fact that guinea pigs are basically just
meat potatoes I prefer to think of
potatoes is like hairless vegetarian
guinea pigs who's your favorite member
of One Direction I don't know if they're
nerdy one hold on I'll call Meredith and
ask who's the nerdiest member of One
Direction all right
Nile thank you Nile is my favorite
member of One Direction I don't know how
to spell his name is it like the river
anyway enough about how old I am let's
move on do you like your handwriting not
really everything I write looks like a
ransom note authored by a seven-year-old
I just read Franny and Zooey and I can't
stop thinking about the quote I'm sick
of not having the courage to be an
absolute nobody what do you think of
that that's one of my favorite lines in
that book actually I think it takes
tremendous courage to do things that are
worth doing rather than like worrying
over whether you're gonna be celebrated
for having done them chocolate chip
cookies or Oreos I think a mint and
chocolate chip cookies and Oreos and the
answer to that is yes if all the
drawings you've ever drawn came to life
and followed you around how would you
react I'd be like man I don't know if
those are horses or giraffes but they
sure are ugly which u.s. president would
you have play a character in The Fault
in Our Stars movie all right Gus is
Obama hazel is Thomas Jefferson Hazel's
mom and dad are respectively Millard
Fillmore and James Kate pol Andrew
Johnson plays Manhattan Isaac is played
by ulysses s grant with no beard Patrick
the support group leader Jimmy Carter
Gus's mom Martin Van Buren Gus's dad
Ronald Reagan I cast the whole movie
Kevin a fishing boat proceeds for 2013
sadly no still no fishing boat proceeds
my tumblr generates lots of gifs but no
income the fishing boat proceeds joke is
now like fully seven years old and
almost no one gets it but I assume that
old nerdfighters will explain it to new
nerdfighters in comments
point am i considered a nerdfighter if
you want to be a nerdfighter you
probably already are one favorite
fairytale growing up the Emperor's New
Clothes favorite Museum in Amsterdam the
Stiglich do penguins have knees yes what
color are your socks green and lastly
John how many backflips can you do I
think you just kind of you go down like
this and then you just just kick your
legs way up and you do a backflip on
zero zero I can do zero backflips smack
I don't wanna make excuses for my
inability to do a backflip but I did get
pretty close to success even though you
know I have a massive cold that was
caused by you Hank I'll see you on
Friday but before I go here is the
teaser one last time I can't do a little
infinity
you